a mind that crossed boundaries and a
polymath who mastered the worlds of both
art and science Leonardo da Vinci may
have been accused of being a heretic yet
he produced some of the most iconic
religious paintings masterpieces as
mysterious as they are renowned
intricate with layer upon layer of
secrets and symbolism here the virgin of
the rocks-- wild yet immaculate dark and
illuminating with discoveries to be
found among the light and shade the
latest way of exploring this work of art
experiencing the science and the
techniques that created this icon what
inspired it how it was painted and not
least how to preserve it a journey that
gradually reveals itself in all its
glory the paintings are really important
one for Leonardo the commission occupied
him for 25 years this is intended to
give people so much rich wonderful
material that their experience of
looking and engaging with the real
Leonardo is deeper and more memorable
and more meaningful here is also a
chance to play with darkness and light
how the master would have seen the
subject bright among the sombre rocks da
Vinci described water as the driving
force of nature it is the architect of
the grotto depicted in the virgin of the
rocks-- painting is also a testament to
the all felt by the artist for the
natural world and the desire he had to
understand it
the version seen here is one of two that
exists the other is in the Louvre in
Paris both almost identical but created
for different Commission's yet what
captivates is the mind behind the work
and the genius that continues to unveil
itself to those who gaze upon it
Sonya Agel al jazeera London